with 10 years of cinematic backstory and
an
endless comic history to draw from every
character in the mcu is worth following
by the time
marvel's infinity saga wraps up but some
receive
more satisfying conclusions than others
from cosmic villains to genius
billionaire playboy philanthropists here
are the avengers in-game character
endings ranked from worst
to best while each member of the black
order gets a pretty epic ending in
avengers infinity war
once you get to end game the group
stumbles a bit
as their 2014 selves face off against
the avengers each of them goes out not
with a bang
but with a whimper ebony ma attempts to
reclaim iron man's infinity gauntlet but
it fails
corvus glaive is quickly stabbed and
tossed aside by okoye
and cull obsidian is unceremoniously
crushed to death by a giant ant-man
their endings are inconsequential to say
the least
despite receiving her own solo film
between infinity war and in-game
captain marvel ended up playing a pretty
minor role in the grand finale
still she does manage to stay busy
saving tony stark and nebula in the
opening moments of the movie
and then arriving in the nick of time to
join in the final battle
but when it comes to the character's
ending it isn't too glamorous
carol danvers is last seen paying her
respects at starks's funeral as the film
wraps up
she looks a bit out of place which makes
sense considering she barely knew tony
the lackluster ending tara cook's story
lands her pretty low on our list
while practically every hero in the
galaxy is present at the final fight in
avengers in-game the armies of wakanda
provide a sea of muscle to back up the
avengers and their allies
standing tall at the head of the
well-trained african army are two
characters who deserve a shout out
okoye and shuri okoye makes her mark on
the proceedings by taking out corvus
glaive
single-handedly while shuri can briefly
be seen blasting away opponents on the
battlefield
but after their splashy entrance they
mostly fade into the background of the
final battle
making their collective ending a bit
less impressive than we might have hoped
iron man's bittersweet ending wouldn't
feel complete without seeing how it
affects the people closest to her
pepper potts morgan stark and of course
happy hogan
appropriately the trio takes the
emotional spotlight in the fading
moments of the film
beginning with tony's final holographic
message after donning her rescue armor
in the film's final battle and
comforting her husband in his last
moments
pepper's last scene sees her bidding ado
to her lost love
as she sets tony's arc reactor adrift on
the lake
meanwhile happy and morgan have a
touching moment on the porch where
tony's daughter shows that she's
inherited her father's appetite
i'm an american cheeseburger you hungry
what do you want cheeseburgers
fondly remembering his former boss happy
promises morgan as many burgers as she
could ever want
it's a sweet fitting goodbye for the
people closest to the infinity saga's
biggest hero
james rhodes aka war machine has
faithfully remained by tony stark's side
throughout the entire mcu
the character stays busy throughout
in-game and his story technically wraps
up on the lakeside as he attends stark's
funeral
however the most emotional part of james
rhodes ending
occurs a few moments earlier in the
seconds after tony stark snaps away
thanos and his army
rhodey is the first one to find his best
friend as he breathes his last
as he realizes what's taking place he
puts his hand to tony's head
and the two brothers in arms share a
quiet moment together
the scene is deeply moving especially
considering what the pair of friends
have gone through up to that point in
time
peter parker gets tangled up in the
thanos storyline early on
when ebony marge giant flying donut
parks right over his hometown
from there the webb head joined stark
and doctor strange on an unplanned trip
to titan
at the end of infinity war parker is
tragically snapped away and he doesn't
reappear until the portals open up in
the climactic ending of end game
no worse for wear after his five years
as dust the crime stopper from queens
swings right back into action
and even carries stark's infinity
gauntlet for a bit he mourns the loss of
his mentor when stark dies
and has a place of honor at the funeral
however his ending gets a little
brighter when he's shown reuniting with
his friend ned setting the stage for his
own solo sequel film
spider-man far from home after doing her
part in the final battle against thanos
valkyrie returns to new asgard where
thor tells her that he's leaving and
likely won't return
when she reminds him that his people
need a king thor informs her that they
already have one
just like that valkyrie is handed the
leadership of asgard
while that seems like a pretty happy
ending it's important to remember the
current state of the kingdom that she's
been tasked with ruling
the surviving asgardians lost their home
planet and many of their countrymen
following thanos's slaughter
the population of new asgard is barely
large enough to fill a town
and it seems a little unfair for thor to
ditch out and leave all his kingly
responsibilities to his second in
command
nevertheless if anyone can turn things
around for the new asgardians
it's valkyrie you know i'd make a lot of
changes around here
i'm counting on it sam wilson and bucky
barnes wind up sharing their final
in-game scene
after a dramatic entrance into the final
battle wilson and barnes help hold back
thanos armies until stark is finally
able to finish them off
from there the two heroes attend stark's
funeral before they head off to witness
professor hulks and captain america
back in time to return the borrowed
infinity stones when steve rogers fails
to return from the quantum realm
sam is concerned but bucky smiles
knowingly the first to understand
steve's choice to remain in the past
moments later when old steve arrives
with his shield and tow
bucky graciously steps aside to let
wilson take up cap's shield
as for sam he's honored when steve
passes the captain america mantle to him
thank you
i'll do my best it's a satisfying
conclusion for their infinity saga
storylines and a great setup for their
own spin-off storyline and the falcon in
the winter soldier
when we first meet the gentle giant
professor hulk it seems like a great new
start to an exciting storyline for bruce
banner and his alter ego
but then the professor hulk narrative
just kind of stalls out
while he's pretty heavily involved in
the time heist his character arc
doesn't really go anywhere his biggest
moment is reversing the snap
it's like
i was made for this the problem is that
in-game was supposed to be hulk's chance
to shine
banner and the big green guy were at
odds throughout infinity war
and it seemed like in-game should have
offered hulk an opportunity to redeem
himself in the battle
but it never quite came while scott
lang's involvement in endgame
definitely pushes the plot forward by
bringing time travel to the table
not much happens with the character
himself hope vandyn's role in the movie
is even smaller since she doesn't appear
into the final battle
so while the pair's endings in endgame
aren't bad they are fairly vanilla
the most they do in the final battle is
help repair louise's van
although that still turns out to be a
dead end afterward we see them back home
watching fireworks with a teenage casey
and they're last shown attending stark's
funeral while the heroes undoubtedly
have a bright future moving forward
their in-game endings aren't
particularly special
after spending the first act of in-game
ruthlessly hunting down
organized crime syndicates and grieving
the loss of his family
clint barton attempts to find redemption
during the time heist
he tries to sacrifice himself to gain
the final infinity stone
but is instead forced to watch his best
friend natasha romanov die in his place
let me go
no please no
clint eventually rediscovers his heroic
roots and spins the final battle working
to get the infinity gauntlet to safety
following his appearance at starks's
funeral clint is last seen sharing a
quiet moment with wanda maximoff as they
both remember their lost loved ones
the scene provides some nice closure for
the infinity saga
and sets the stage for each of the
pair's solo spin-off series
but is dampened a little if you recall
clint's dark and violent actions in the
first half of the film
after being willing to sacrifice
everything she had in order to defeat
thanos at the end of infinity war wanda
maximoff returns thirsty for vengeance
at the end of in-game
and who can blame her thanks to thanos
destructive actions
wanda had to kill vision whom she loved
only to then be forced to watch
thanos kill him again the scarlet witch
takes on thanos mono amano in the final
battle of end game
and likely would have killed him if he
hadn't been willing to destroy his own
troops in order to stop her
later she finds some peace talking to
hawkeye finding comfort in her belief
that vision and natasha know their
sacrifices weren't in vain
she knows
they both do despite being dusted for
most of the movie
steven strange paves the way for the
events of endgame
by having willingly surrendered the time
stone at the end of infinity war
although strange gets snapped moments
later his action
steers the surviving avengers toward
their 1 in 14 million chance at a
victorious outcome
once he's brought back to life by
professor hulk snap strange and his
fellow masters of the mystic arts
open up numerous portals enabling
thousands of heroic troops to join the
battle
then right when it seems as though
thanos's victory is inevitable
strange finally reveals to stark that
they are indeed
operating within that 1 in 14 million
timeline
we last see strange paying his respects
at tony's funeral
leaving him in a prime position to
continue playing a critical role in
phase four
for all intents and purposes gamora
shouldn't have had an ending in end game
at all
but it turned out that the 2014 version
of the heroine
ultimately becomes the replacement for
the 2018 gamora who died in infinity war
after jumping forward in time gamora
turns on her adoptive father during the
final battle and is present for stark's
death
in a deleted endgame scene it was
revealed that afterward the confused
2014 version of the character departs
quietly for destinations unknown
this open-ended finale is a fun one
mostly because of how unexpected it is
with the universe at stake the noble
king t'challa
is the first to step through strange's
portals he joins the battle with shuri
okoye and a host of wakandan soldiers at
his back
in the ensuing conflict the wakandan
armies play a critical role in resisting
thanos's hordes with t'challa even
helping to keep the stark gauntlet safe
from thanos
after the fight the king in his country
can be seen reveling in their
reunification
before t'challa shuri and okoye attend
stark's funeral
while t'challa's final moments in end
game aren't particularly flashy
they ended up being the last scenes that
actor chadwick boseman filmed for the
role before he tragically passed away
this makes those scenes especially
significant serving as bozeman's
unexpected farewell to the mcu as a
whole
while gamora's final moments in end game
are somewhat bittersweet
the rest of the guardians of the galaxy
have happier endings
rocket and groot finally reunite after
five years apart
star-lord finds hope in the fact that
gamora is still alive
and drax and mantis continue to provide
moments of unintentional hilarity
the best part of the guardians of the
galaxy's in-game ending though
is that it turned out not to be the last
time we'd see the team working together
just months before in-game hit theaters
the long-derailed third guardians
installment got back on track
with original director james gunn back
at the helm this allowed the in-game
writers to weave the future of the
guardians into endgame
culminating in the scene where the
guardians are preparing to leave earth
with thor to find gamora
the excitement of their reunions as well
as the humor of their departure
ranks as one of the better
multi-character endings in the film
thor goes through the ringer in infinity
war and seems to hit rock bottom and end
game
but after some much needed inspiration
from his mother during the time heist
he finally reclaimed some of his lost
confidence after that
the son of odin resumes his god-like
ways wielding both mjolnir and
stormbreaker in his electrifying fight
against thanos
after the defeat of the mad titan thor
spends his final moments of end game
passing off his kingly duties to
valkyrie
and joining up with the guardians of the
galaxy
he has guardians of the galaxy back
together again
thor is last seen subtly challenging
star-lord for leadership
ending in-game on a fun note for his
character
the conflicted daughter of thanos is
actually featured twice in avengers
in-game
and both nebulas receive solid endings
the primary nebula wraps up her journey
by helping in the climactic battle
attending tony stark's funeral and then
joining the guardians of the galaxy
the former villain's redemptive journey
is full of promise with her dark
past literally left in ashes on the
battlefield however 2014 nebula's ending
is
less positive though still moving she
spends the majority of the movie
tragically tethered to father's every
whim
bringing the sanctuary 2 through the
time machine and nearly killing hawkeye
in her attempt to reclaim the infinity
gauntlet
at that moment gamora and the other
nebula arrive and attempt to talk her
out of the deed
unable to change she's eventually shot
and killed by her older self
a tear runs down her cheek as she dies
bringing a heartbreaking ending to a
deeply conflicted character
original avenger natasha romanov's
character arc is shockingly cut short in
endgame
in fact she's the only one on the list
whose ending wraps up before the third
act of the film
up until this point romanov's mcu
journey has always been one of
redemption
starting with red in her ledger the
super spy consistently worked to make
amends for her past and her mcu
appearances throughout the infinity saga
her story abruptly ended when she
sacrificed herself to get the soul stone
halfway through in-game in the end
natasha's universe saving sacrifice
becomes one of endgame's most powerful
endings even if it meant she wasn't
around to participate in the film's
grand finale
[Music]
while most of the best endings in
in-game belong to heroes
thanos scores highly on the list by
receiving two satisfying endings
the 2018 version of the villain meets
his end early on in the film
when he's hunted down by the avengers
and decapitated by thor
this is actually closest to the ending
thanos wanted
not only does he wipe out half of the
universe but he prevents his victory
from being undone by destroying the
infinity stones
but he never could have predicted that
the avengers will go back in time
to walk back his success during the time
heist
2014 thanos emerges as the avengers
ultimate foe once again
this leads to its final ending in which
he and his armies are poetically snapped
away into the wind
captain america's story arc stretches
nearly the entire length of the infinity
saga before it finally comes full circle
and in game
steve rogers path begins during world
war ii when he's transformed from a 90
pound weakling into a super soldier of
epic proportions
his journey eventually catapults him
into the 21st century where he becomes a
founding member of the avengers
by endgame cap has evolved from
patriotic soldier to universe saving
team leader
and his final act includes several
moments that fans waited nearly a decade
to see
avengers
assemble from that long-awaited line to
his opportunity to finally wield me only
are in battle
in-game is full of opportunities for
steve to shine
ultimately though it's his chance to go
back in time and get that dance with
peggy carter
that truly feels like the ending he
deserves after a lifetime spent feeling
out of place
and at the service of others steve
finally gets a life for himself
how'd that work out for you
it's beautiful the entire marvel
cinematic universe kicks off with tony
stark's pivot from a narcissistic
playboy
into a bonafide superhero early in his
journey
tony proves that he's willing to
sacrifice himself for the greater good
when he flies a nuke into space
and hurls it at a chittari ship when he
survives the next several years see an
ancient stark doing his best to prepare
for the next world-ending threat
only to still fail when he faces thanos
on titan in in game though
he gets a second shot at saving the
world after realizing that the one
version of reality where they win can
only be achieved by sacrificing himself
he doesn't hesitate stark snaps away
every last one of thanos's soldiers
knowing it means he'll never see his
family again
[Music]
iron man the heroic act marks the end of
the world's greatest hero
but his selfless sacrifice makes it the
best character ending in the film
i love you three thousand check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one